y del presidente del gobierno de España
ha decidido iniciar la presidencia
rotatoria del Consejo de la Unión
Europea en kiev Pedro Sánchez flanqueado
por las banderas ucranianas y europea
habló durante 15 minutos en el
parlamento Donde ha reforzado una vez
más el apoyo inquebrantable de Europa al
país invadido cualquiera que sea el
coste ha dicho Sánchez tras su discurso
en la rada se reunía con voley mirza
lensky y en la agenda había dos temas
centrales por un lado la posible
adhesión de Ucrania a la Unión Europea a
la que España se muestra favorable en
octubre se conocerá el informe oficial
de la comisión europea sobre su ingreso
un proceso usualmente lento pero que
quiere acelerar Aunque por ahora quien
solo cumple con dos de los siete
requisitos exigidos por Bruselas por
otro lado la protagonista es América
Latina con la que celenski pretende que
España haga de Puente durante estos seis
meses Ucrania tiene interés en reforzar
relaciones con latinoamérica y ganar
apoyos a su plan de paz en una región
con más lazos históricos económicos y
comerciales con Rusia sin embargo en una
entrevista a medios españoles el viernes
selenski que algunos países
latinoamericanos aunque no menciono
Cuáles no estaban muy de acuerdo en que
Ucrania asistiera como invitado a la
Cumbre Unión Europea la prevista para el
17 y 18 de julio en Bruselas una cita
que no se da desde 2015 y en la que
España quiere pactar acuerdos
comerciales Como por ejemplo entre la
Unión Europea y mercosur para este
semestre España tiene cuatro prioridades
la unidad la red industrialización para
poder competir con Estados Unidos y
China la transición ecológica que
reduzca la dependencia energética del
continente y una mayor justicia social y
fiscal